so there's a new bill in the congress
called the
endless frontier act and the idea behind
it
is kind of hard to criticize you don't
imagine anyone could be against a piece
of legislation that aims to help the
united states
beat china in manufacturing and
technology
but we thought it'd be interesting to
hear from one of its critics
what's in it exactly senator john
kennedy serves the state of louisiana
the united states senate
he joins us now to explain his view of
this bill senator thanks so much
for coming on so i i know you agree
that the idea behind the bill sounds
great
you're saying that the reality of the
bill falls far short of great
tell us how
well let me apologize in advance for any
mean ugly accurate things i'm about to
say
senator schumer has a bill as you said
endless frontiers act
um it's um it is right now before the
senate
uh it is an orgy of spending and very
little bit of the money
goes to the military here is a copy of
the bill
uh it started out at 40 billion dollars
it the budget office tells me it's up to
200 billion and growing like kudzu
it's probably going to pass because i
say this gently but
some of my republican colleagues have
swapped brains with the democrats and
are going to vote for it
senator schumer is ecstatic he's running
around like a
a five-year-old in a batman costume
here's what the bill will do 120 billion
dollars in foreign aid
i don't know why we can't use that money
for infrastructure i don't know why we
have to give money to countries that
hate us
they should be able to hate us for free
50 billion dollars to the big
tech semiconductor companies we all know
how broke
big tech is uh i i guess they can use
the money to
develop more efficient algorithms to
censors
uh 80 billion dollars to the infamous
national
science foundation this is the same
national science foundation
that spent 500 000 in taxpayer money
studying how long it takes pandas to
poop
the answer is 12 minutes by the way they
need more fiber
uh it spent three million dollars the
nsf did
uh seeing to see if students can tell
the difference between toilet water
and bottled water uh they spent another
five hundred thousand dollars to study
whether shrimp can run on treadmills
under water
and i could keep going for an hour uh
here's my point
and this is my opinion others disagree
with me um
my mother did not raise a fool and if
she did it was one of my brothers
this is not a fight communism bill
if you look at this bill and study it
you will see
this is a all four feet and your
snout in the trough spending bill
with virtually no money going for
military defense
may i ask just a stupid question um and
i'm sorry about your brothers by the way
uh why would a bill designed
to help american manufacturing contain
foreign aid i have no
idea well yes i do tucker here's what
happened this started out as a fairly
small bill
if you can call 40 billion dollars small
and then
everybody piled on and senator schumer
desperately wants to pass the bill so he
cut
everybody in on the spending and that's
why i say it is an
orgy of spending porn i'm not saying
that every penny
in here is wasteful i'm saying an
enormous
amount is wasteful and here we are
talking about our
president biden is raising taxes to pay
for infrastructure
why can't we use some of this money to
pay for infrastructure
uh that's all i'm saying yeah um
everybody
everybody in washington is forced is for
is for fiscal responsibility they want
to cut spending
but everybody in washington is it's like
going to heaven
they want to go to heaven but they don't
want to take the trip it's
amazing senator thanks so much for
joining us
tonight and giving us a window into how
things actually work
i appreciate it thanks tucker hey sean
hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else